we're all pretty rational it's quite a
robust thinking system that we've got
between our ears but what's going to
happen and has been happening for
several millennia now is we're going to
develop more and better thinking tools
and we're going to identify more
weaknesses in our rationality and a
weakness identified is at least
something that can be avoided to some
degree we can learn workarounds we can
we can recognize that we're suckers for
certain sorts of bad ideas and alerted
to that we can we can flag them when
they come up I think that process of a
sort of self-knowledge and self
purification of reasoning processes will
will continue slowly to to develop so
it's not so much although it might
include the development of actual you
know software technology to help us
think that's part of it as we all know
but also just the self knowledge that
alerts us to faibles blind spots in our
own thinking we probably can't repair
them with any technology we might not
want to repair them the costs might be
too great might stunt us in some other
way but at least we can we can know them
and of course that idea is is an ancient
idea that goes way back to Socrates you
know know thyself and that Socratic
injunction has been the we've been
following it for several millennia with
good results
you